one of the most memorable things about a
movie character is how they're
introduced to the viewer and how the
film lets the viewer know who they are
and why they matter with that in mind
here are some of the best character
introductions in the history of film the
vito corleone Francis Ford Coppola's
1972 masterpiece a godfather opens with
a Mariko buona sera telling a
complicated story that leads to an
account of his daughter's brutal assault
at the hands of two men it's clear he's
talking to someone highly respected and
very dangerous and there's the shot
grows wider were introduced to this
mysterious man from behind when Bonasera
gets up to whisper in Don Corleone Zia
we understand exactly what kind of just
as he seeks Corleone doesn't betray any
emotion in response to what he's been
asked but takes buona sera to task
nonetheless he meet him as a Godfather
a man so powerful he literally decides
who lives and who dies Hannibal Lecter
when FBI trainee Clarice Starling enters
the dungeon-like hallway that leads to
Hannibal Lecter self viewers have
already heard about the brutal
cannibalistic serial killer she's on her
way to meet Starling sees a succession
of horrifying men in the cells along the
way so after all the setup is something
of a surprise when Lecter finally comes
into view his stat is clean and has art
hanging on the walls dr. Lecter my name
is Clarice Starling that speak with you
you're one of Jack prophets aren't you I
am yes even as he's being friendly to
Clarice there's something a nerving
about him he's being polite but he's
also testing her in every moment it's
thought that Hannibal that day isn't a
monster it's just so he's an
extraordinarily civilized one Batman Tim
Burton's 1989 version of Batman Begins
with a scene that suggests the
characters well-known origin as a boy
and his parents are accosted by hoodlums
and the back alleys of Gotham City these
are the Wayne's however and they
survived the mugging the two criminals
find the nearby perch and starts sorting
through their spoils more discussing
recent sightings of a bat-like figure
attacking criminals as they talk the
recognizable silhouette of Batman
descends behind them before the dark
nights easily kick their butts
I'm not going to kill you I'd like you
to do me a favor I want you to tell all
your friends about me I'm Batman Darth
Vader a brigade of white armored
stormtroopers briefs a rebel starship
Dontae for first engaging in a shootout
that leaves many rebels dead and the
ship filled with smoke with the rebels
on the run the stormtroopers stunned
that attention as Darth Vader enters the
scene it's immediately clear beta is
extremely powerful and he doesn't do the
grunt work the nature of Darth Vader's
power will become clear in later scenes
but for now it's enough that he's very
big very scary and in charge
quint Steven Spielberg's 1975 classic
jaws as a movie about a deadly shark but
it's also a movie about a town in crisis
selfishly searching for a solution to
keep their tourism industry alive this
comes to a head in a scene where all the
town leaders are meeting and everyone is
talking at once Robert Shaw's quinten's
his jaws very late but this scene
quickly makes clear what sort of man he
is
he's extremely competent and he knows it
but he's also disinterested in polite
social norms he's not the guy anyone
wants to work with but he's the guy who
can catch a giant shark ten thousand
dollars for me by myself for that you
get the head the tail the whole damn
thing thanks for watching click the loop
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff you
know you're lifting
[Music]